right the European Union and Brazil have
a well-established partnership based
upon a common Heritage and shared
fundamental values and principles such
as democracy human rights fundamental
Freedom social inclusions and
sustainable development Brazil and the
EU also share strong culture and
historical ties and Brazil was one of
the first countries to establish
diplomatic relations with the EU and is
now a long-standing strategic partner of
the EU needless to say the EU is
following closely International
Development in Brazil particularly
against the background of the turmoil
that followed the election of President
Lula in January this year we're also
very much interested in the new world
Brazil intends to play on the
international scene and it attempts to
work on a peaceful settlement settlement
of the Russian war of aggression against
Ukraine however some of the statements
made by Brazilian authorities last week
which seemed to indicate the willingness
to side with Russia and to put on an
equal footing the aggressor and the
aggressed in this brutal and unjustified
War are puzzling to put it mildly I'm
glad that President Lula made some
important clarifications afterwards and
we would welcome a clear position from
Brazil on this issue which is
fundamental for us all in Europe
in parallel we are witnessing a welcome
renewed momentum on the mercosur
agreement which would undoubtedly boost
the already strong Brazil EU trade
relations with all this in mind I was in
I invited Miss Veronica Lorenzo head of
the vision for
for South America and the external
Action Service to give us an account of
the latest development in Brazil and on
the state of play of the mercosur
agreement so without further Ado the
floor goes to miss Lorenzo for 10
minutes
thank you very much Mrs chair thank you
for the invitation to the uh to the EAS
we're very pleased to our relations with
Brazil are extremely important this is
one of our two strategic Partners in the
region and the the relationship has not
lived up to that status of of strategic
partnership
up to now and from the beginning of this
new government our purpose has been to
uh to really
step up and and comply with with our
purpose which is to revitalize
relationship with Brazil
um since the beginning of the year since
the beginning beginning of President
Lula's term with I think we have started
to comply with this objective and we've
had an extremely
um busy calendar of meetings of contacts
uh and that clearly shows the interest
on both sides to to re-engaged we've had
exchanges between President Lula and
president of the commission president of
the council
um HIV P burghel has had several
meetings with his counterparts foreign
minister martovieda we've had two
missions so far by EVP vestiga and EVP
timmermans and these have been the
opportunity to start discussions on how
to restart that that relationship and
deepen cooperation on on crucial themes
like climate change environment and
digital development
there are several other missions in the
pipeline including bayafet by the
delegation for Brazil by Inta Envy also
by Commissioners Johansson and
sinkovichus and possibly the president
of the of the commission and of course
when we look at president Lula's busy
International agenda it's very clear
that Brazil is back as a global player
um perhaps let me start referring to
what you mentioned uh now about uh that
has been in the headlines over the past
few weeks uh we've all heard president
Lula's statements on the Russian
invasion uh of Ukraine during his
mission to China and to the United Arab
Emirates
first of all I think it's important to
say that we appreciate Brazil's support
for the multilateral order and its clear
condemnation of the Russian war of
aggression against Ukraine in
multilateral fora including in the UN
General Assembly and more recently as
weak in fact president Lula has repeated
that in in Portugal and and yesterday in
Spain
but defending the U.N Charter also means
that there can be no equidistance
between aggressor and attacked and if
Russia stops its aggression and
withdraws from Ukraine and territory the
war ends if Ukraine stops defending
itself Ukraine will be destroyed in the
nation and the country would cease to
exist
the Russian war is an imperialistic War
aimed at recreating the outdated spheres
of influence not from Soviet times but
from the time of the Russian Empire
we want what president Lula wants and
then to this war that has been imposed
by Russia on its neighbor
as you mentioned chair president Lula
himself later clarified his statements
um and I believe the it's very clear
they're not buying into the Russian
narrative
but they're not unequivocally
buying our narrative to the full extent
either and a uh
this I think underlines the need for us
to strengthen our dialogue and our
engagement at all levels bilaterally
regionally and globally
if I turn and you've asked me to to give
you an update of where we are in the in
the prongs of our in the dimensions of
our relationship I would mention three
themes our bilateral relationship our
strategic partnership secondly the where
we are in the conclusion of the
agreement with with EU mercosur and
thirdly our engagement in Regional and
and global forum
so to to start with this this strategic
partner as I mentioned uh already from
the start of the Year an important
number of uh steps have have been taken
and that has given the the framework uh
for our future joint work and these are
the the themes uh we're working on the
mission by VP timmermans in in January
was the an opportunity to step up
dialogue and cooperation on climate
change and environment
and what's been discussed is the uh the
launching of a high level Dialogue on
climate change and environment at
ministerial level and the
intensification of joint work on green
hydrogen
and to see that's one one of the themes
that is an irritant is the EU
legislation on the deforestation free
value chains and we need to see how to
uh better work together to explain and
cooperate for the better implementation
of of this legislation
the mission by VP vestaga in March
was clearly highlighted the scope for
synergies in the area of digicoto
digital cooperation Science and
Technology Brazil has a keen interests
to discuss digital inclusiveness and to
continue the exchange on best regulatory
approaches concerning digital platforms
digital markets and artificial
intelligence and also to re-establish
the high level Dialogue on Information
Society and the digital economy
to discuss how to deepen the cooperation
that has been very fruitful in the in
the past years in science and technology
these are priorities for Brazil their
priorities for for us they are a very
positive agenda that need to be
pursued we're working on that and of
course there are many more areas we need
to to explore including different themes
that are rising in the agenda such as
security and defense or the increasing
problem of addressing organized crime
if I turn to the second part which is
the conclusion of the EU medical Sur
agreement
um we have I think we we've all heard
the uh the the the latest declarations
and from both sides there's Keen
interests to to conclude
um the latest
um was a meeting in early March by the
chief negotiators and and they clearly
demonstrated the the renewed momentum
we agreed we would not be reopening
texts that were concluded for the trade
bite in 2019 for the political
incorporation part in 2020
um and that all efforts would be made to
try and
and reach a conclusion by The Summit one
of the main outstanding issues is the
additional instruments that details
aspects of sustainability of the
agreement that draft was for the first
time presented to America suit Partners
in Buenos Aires and they have expressed
concerns we are still waiting for
comments on their side but we know that
as I mentioned the youth legislation on
deforestation free value chains this is
one of their main concerns
they're concerned about the impacts of
the Eugene deal legislation and they
argued that this has changed the goal
posts that were negotiated in the
agreement we reached in 2019 by
introducing new requirements for exports
to the EU
they also want the text to better
reflect environmental concerns will go
hand in hand with some other of their
priorities such as social inclusion and
economic development so at this stage I
think it's important we're open to their
concerns
um we are awaiting uh their reaction to
this the next round of negotiations
should take place in May and of course
we have been very very open in
expressing that that uh
we're ready to to cooperate
to provide cooperation to accompany the
implementation of of this agreement
thirdly I turn to the uh the to the
Brazil in the as a regional and and
global global player
um and in our efforts to reinvigorate EU
Lac relations Brazil is Central uh we
would have been several dimashas and we
sincerely hope that President Lula will
be able to attend the EU select Summit
in July on the 17th and 18th of July and
Brazil of course is a key player to find
Solutions in Regional issues Regional
Crisis such as Venezuela both countries
have re-established relations recently
the Diplomatic advisor to president Lula
Mr amoring visited Venezuela in March we
as the EU are extremely
committed to a resolution of the crisis
and we believe that jointly we can we
could be an important lever towards
finding a peaceful and Democratic way
out of the crisis so both EU and Brazil
can only gain by working closer together
we have as you know strong cultural
interpersonal ties we share the same
values we have strong trades still we're
still the stronger the strongest
investor in Brazil and we're now really
implementing what we said we would do
which is to step up our dialogue and and
cooperation now is the time to deliver
on this on this partnership we need to
find a landing spot for the EU medical
agreement and deliver more on the on
what has been the framework that has
been traced by the missions of EVPs
vestaga and and timmermans
I think your forthcoming missions to
Brazil will be an important piece of
that that building block of that edifice
um and of course we stand ready to
support any of your efforts thank you
very much
well it's working thank you um thank you
very much Mr learn so so we will
continue our exchange of use with the
chair of parliament delegation for
relations with the federative Republic
of Brazil Mr Jose Manuel Fernandez Mr
Fernandez you have the floor for two
minutes thank you thank you very much I
will speak Portuguese
thank you very much Madam chair
I also wanted to
congratulate Mrs Lorenzo for all the
hard work that she's made on this
operation and the key word is really
cooperation we need to look at Africa
and Latin America and try to negotiate
bearing in mind not not thinking that
we're at the Forefront everywhere but
rather just to try to embark on joint
development based on European values
democracy freedom
defense of human life and human dignity
and the ease should serve as the basis
for development as regards Latin America
Brazil is a fundamental country and it's
essential important and even crucial
that it advances towards the EU merkos
or agreement this agreement represents
150 million people 25 percent of global
GDP and it would not only allow for a
geopolitical order that is based on the
values that I've just mentioned but also
it would be a win-win
on both sides and we mustn't fear moving
forward towards merkosurb on the basis
of protectionism which may exist in a
variety of areas Brazil is the fifth
largest country in the world it
represents about half of the Latin
American population
and half of the population of the
European Union it's the 12th largest
world economy and in terms of
cooperation there's much that can be
done in the area of digital technology
the environment climate change
forestries the sea defense of Human
Rights and therefore I think it is
essential
and indeed it would be extremely
positive for example for in July at the
SLX Summit that we conclude this
agreement
even to try to build peace because peace
is an essential precondition for
cooperation and so this is what I am
putting forth word I think it's the
position that the EU should take and
specifically the European Parliament
thinking
if an additional
Edition
for two minutes
[Music]
thank you very much Madam chair
after my compatriots and colleagues Jose
Manuel Fernandez
righteous words I can say very little
except for emphasize the importance of
the agreement EU merkos are especially
given that at the moment Brazil is
experiencing a
profound change when it comes to its
environmental policy and
over the last few years in Brazil its
environment policy has been a problem
and an obstacle towards
progress in the mercosur agreement but
provided that Brazil
is ready to Launch
in the carbon trading market and It
prepares
um forestry programs that fight
deforestation and even recover Forest
both in the forest and in the Mata
Atlantica
so
then we should we have everything we
need to stop
postponing this agreement and to
actually make progress on it it is of
vital importance not just for Portugal
or Spain or a subset of EU countries is
it of vital importance to all of us
because from a strategic point of view
this is going to Define
action and cooperation of extreme
importance and it's also extremely
important for Latin America
for a number of reasons and also because
there is an urgent absolutely urgent
need to
resolve the conflict in Venezuela
towards
democracy and peace and this is
something that we need to do and this
agreement gives us the necessary
foundations to be able to strengthen our
connection so that this can become a
reality and
here
let us talk about the agreement the need
to establish this agreement
but I'd like to know more about the
actual timetable that we're going to
follow because it's all very well to
talk about objectives but we need to
have concrete clear objectives thank you
very much and for um we knew we don't
have anyone green snow I did know put
the left be qualis
thanks very much
um
you made the point that Lula hasn't
bought into the Russian narrative on the
war and you say that neither has he
bought into the EU us NATO narrative
um and you say there might be need for
more dialogue uh with him on that basis
um is there not an acceptance that I
mean it's very important of course that
he doesn't buy into the Russian
narrative but he is calling for peace
and he is on the side of
countries containing over 80 percent of
the world's population
who are refusing to take sides are
looking for peace and Lula is clearly in
this camp and is unlikely to move out of
it
and surely we sh this idea that you're
either with us are against us as
originally caused by Bush back in 2003
when he was illegally invaded in Iraq
surely this is not a healthy way forward
and that if countries are not taking
sides and are looking for peace
if if the EU isn't going to respect that
position we're not going to be isolating
ourselves from over 80 percent of the
world's population thank you
um we have Mr Angel for DPP
thank you very much Cher I will speak in
Portuguese because I'd like to recall
everybody that Portuguese language is
the fifth in the world
the third in the west and the first in
the South Hemisphere and Brazil is the
only country from the brics that has as
official language and only language and
European language
first of all
I'd like to say
how much I admire the work of my
colleges there Manuel Fernandez
president of the delegation in extremely
difficult circumstances
in a very hostile counterpart in the
hospital environment in the European
Union and the pandemic has very much
made work difficult and I know that this
will be resumed in May in a very
effective way with the presence in
Brazil and then
I won't say anything more about the
mercosur agreement because my two
previous colleagues were very clear
about that
I would ever like to touch upon three
points
the first
is Brazil's position towards Russia
which has caused a bit of
perplexed responses but in their
assembly they were always in favor of
Peace in the international Arena and now
in the Lisbon declaration The Joint
Lisbon declaration Lula I think Whiteley
said item was in fact
encouraged by our party the Epp and very
rightly managed to have a declaration
which was
considerably
far beyond what Lula has normally said
there are some contradictions between
this declaration and previous ones but
it's progress and this has to do with
our political partnership with Brazil
because the European Union hasn't done
very much during the bolsonaro
presidency it was very difficult but
really haven't done much because if we
had a much more intense relationship
with Brazil then clearly Brazil will
come closer to your positions for
reasons that Mrs Renzo explained that is
we have cultural affinities tremendous
cultural affinities and so in fact
perhaps they're even closer to us from a
cultural point of view than
the United States
also Brazil has a relationship with
Africa which is also
good for us and it's there's a triangle
Brazil Africa and the European Union so
this is something important and then one
final note I'd like to point out that
President Lula and Brazil in its
external policy has
desire to have a permanent seat in the
security Council even if it doesn't have
a vote and
um the European Union should support
this and also for the European Union to
have a seat in the security Council even
if it does initially not have a veto
right thank you
um and um for SMD we have Sanchez and
more not just such gracias
foreign
stuck strictly to the script and I do
apologize for having to say this the
very boring script it's like the two
British MPS who got lost somewhere in
the countryside
when they were on an electoral campaign
and they asked a Shepherd where are we
and the shepherd said
well in a car and one of the MPS said
this is a perfect example of a
parliamentary reply it's perfectly
correct it's true but it doesn't provide
an
ounce of information extra to what we
knew before and I must admit I have an
impression the same impression when we
listen to the EAS
and um hearing here in the effort
committee what we've read in the Press
over the couple of weeks is a bit
frustrating there was a session together
with the ambassador of Brazil
when the
um ambassador
on the mercosur agreement said that they
weren't going to accept a dictat which
is a political position of course
and we said
Mr Fernandez and us and we said well
this is something we've been negotiating
now for 20 years so I don't really think
you could see it as a dictat in that
kind of way and we've also seen that
Brazil has placed on the table a kind of
old additional alternative statement
so the negotiations that would appear
perhaps you can confirm this but Brazil
has announced a negotiating position or
an additional alternative protocol and
given that all of us in this but in this
house wish to bring an end to this
never-ending file because of the nature
of the file and the overall geopolitical
environment in which this agreement will
in fit in then I think we are entitled
to know what's going on you have very
carefully
um guarded the commissions and
negotiating position is that I think
shows a little interest you have and I
don't know whether we are really going
to be the
[Music]
Guardians of this agreement
so in the light of what you've said and
uh we would like to know if you have any
additional information how the
negotiations going what about the
negotiating process is there an
alternative text that has been submitted
by Brazil because those the kind of
things that are of interest to our
Parliament
on everything relating to Russia I've
taken note of Mr rajel
and I think if there's more contact uh
well I think all of us are rather
surprised by this position
because obviously this well this is uh
considerably a far removed from the
solidarity expressed by bolsonaro with
Russia I think it might be useful for
the president to come to Europe because
he was there in Portugal yesterday Spain
today and I think it might help
president Lula get a better idea of what
our perspective and position is I am
concluding we do have a lot of
expectations in this new climate with
Brazil but I think we really have to fix
them and finalize the agreement because
of the geopolitical concern
um
for renew
there's no
yeah we have uh Lopez Chavi chubby Lopez
thank you very much
not a chair if I can continue on what
veronique was saying we had a very
complete presentation concerning the
relations between Brazil and the
European Union
first of all Brazil is back uh you've
said that yourself back on the
international stage and
doing the well putting right some of the
things that uh will continue with what
the previous uh Lula government did
multilateralism Etc then the markers are
agreement obviously they have strategic
interest in that and they're also
playing a specific role on the
international scene and I think if we
want to build Bridges with others
Brazil is a very large country so
political diploma diplomatic ties and we
know what the situation is like very
quickly on Russia
I think in Lisbon and in Madrid some of
these positions have been clarified
relating to Brazil any peace initiative
obviously is more than welcome as long
it is as long as it is based on the fact
that you have an aggressor and then an
injured party
obviously there are other we've got the
Asia we've got Africa India
and their positions on the wall
which is a different
so obviously that's the world outside
the NATO alliance that we form part of
the NATO alliance so their understanding
is different and I think what we have to
do is explain more more awareness so and
do this at the United Nations then three
specific questions there was a reference
to environmental cooperation and the
fight against climate change I think
this is absolutely essential
there's also another area of cooperation
when it comes to uh
the manufacturing economy productive
economy which is very important for Lula
other areas of South America because
they want to move away from a mining
industry to a more productive economy
when it comes to the mercosur agreement
and to be quite Frank
um we have the Eis position yes but I
don't really know what Europe's position
is
and that's something I think that's
rather different because when the
president speaks so we hear that yes
there is an agreement we want to
introduce more elements into it and they
say well
if you want to introduce other elements
into the agreement then we have to
discuss this negotiate this which is
quite reasonable but the the president
in France uh has given a public opinion
on this on the agreement and we've heard
positions from the Dutch Parliament so I
don't know whether we in Europe agree to
what is being negotiated in agreement
we've heard some more valuable comments
today and I think this is the problem
and because obviously the other side in
these negotiations will have noted what
everybody else in Europe is saying on
this and then
Brazil we've we know of course that
um the presidency of selag has not been
very tough and I think we need a better
presence so that we can have a more
relevant agenda uh leaving aside the
whole plan of Investments but I think we
have to have a true agenda for the
region thank you
and finally
um Bennett
president
thank you chair
on the question of Lula's declaration
about Russia and Ukraine
I think that explanation is very clear
it can be summed up in a word
Lula is a Latin American
and of course
like all Latin Americans are almost all
he has
psychological historical and economic
relations which are extremely complex
with the United States
like most Latin Americans Lula is
reticent with respect to the idea that
the United States could continue to play
a dominant role in the international
Arena and is delighted at the idea that
the United States
wait in the international Arena could be
moderated
and this is why he has that position so
what should we conclude from this could
we contend condemn him
and I condemn his declarations but
politically what should we do well
one thing is simple is the more the
European Union asserts itself in the
international Arena the less Lula and
many Latin Americans will be
uncomfortable or worried about
diplomatic economic and Industrial
hegemony on the part of the United
States in the international Arena and
therefore let's exist let's pull our
weight talk about talk to Latin America
and specifically with Lula because this
can considerably change things and
in particular very quickly or perhaps
not very quickly but certainly quickly
this could
really
break this front of the global South
because
Lula
um unlike others is a Democrat thank you
um and um oh thank you very much and I
will give you back the floor to us for
these questions
thank you very much chair
um let me perhaps I mean the word there
were several themes one around the
medical Sur agreement one about position
how to
behave in a way with Brazil in terms of
their position on on Russia and perhaps
a couple of of points
um on our relationship
um let me start I'll speak in Portuguese
if you don't mind
um
I would just like to disagree with you
because I think that
what we've been saying over the last few
years
and it's been over four years that I've
been working on this issue and
for at least two years we couldn't say
anything
because
there was no political will or even the
appropriate conditions to make any
progress we were working continually on
from a technical point of view on this
additional instrument which I think does
address many of the concerns about
sustainability and particularly
deforestation but this instrument was
put on the back burner for a long time
because there because of the political
context but now with the new government
the new Environmental Policy the
situation changed changes completely and
you can see you could see it from the
beginning of the year that there is a
great deal of Will on both sides of the
Atlantic to make progress now
I could be spell it out a little bit
more as regards the timetable that we
hope to complete
the first thing is of the utmost
importance
and that was the first meeting that we
had in March of the chief negotiators
and clearly it said that neither a party
wants to reopen the agreement
and that is fundamental there there
wasn't that certainty before that
meeting took place so that's one point
and then a timetable of meetings
monthly meetings was set and it is
difficult to
agree on the June Summit but that is the
goal
it's the explicit goal on both sides
so
read a meeting of 12 Chief negotiators
every month the next one will be at the
end of May the one after that will be in
June and we hope
that
the agreements will be concluded so that
it can be announced at the July Summit
and
we have more details we'll present this
additional instrument which for so long
was stagnating mercos had been asking us
for this text for two years and we
couldn't share it with them
there was a strong response from Brazil
in particular which
on the one hand there are things for
example
the Paris agreements these are
intentional
the additional instrument establishes
that
the commitment is compulsory these are
things that they don't like
and then there's a whole part which
they think that the instrument is
imbalanced because there is a part where
they have their priorities social
inclusion development of industrial
policy and so forth which is not
included and so it is true that they
said that there's going to be
an alternate proposal to the additional
instrument but we still haven't received
that alternative proposal which ought to
be shared before the meeting at the end
of May so that's where we stand
so
I'd like to repeat politically our
situation is entirely different from
what it was a few months ago
and this political support comes from us
the European Union at the highest level
that is at the part on the part of the
presidency of the European Union
um
there are other problems and that's
going to be a matter of us
presenting this agreement for the
approval of member states and we'll see
what happens
as regards relations with Russia we
don't believe in the uh you're either
with us or against us that I've
mentioned the fact that we need to
continue the dialogue to strengthen the
dialogue to and to have it at all
different levels this is how we can it
explain the issue the perspectives are
very different from Brazil it's a it's a
war that's far for them it's not for us
it's a question of survival and these
things need to be a lot of these this
needs to be explained
we don't
we can agree to disagree we will never
be completely in agreement with Brazil
over in that position with Russia they
will never agree to sanctions this is
embedded in their long foreign policy
tradition okay you know we we take notes
we we don't have the same position but
that does not prevent us from moving
ahead and and and and strengthening our
relations
lastly I would say that I think I I
really think what I've said over the
last few years and we've worked together
with uh
thank you for recognizing the hard work
of mephism Fernandez they were difficult
years
but I would like to say that we've
always said that our relationship with
Brazil is of utmost importance and it's
goes much farther than just a
relationship with the government it's a
relationship with the country for the
reasons that the MEP has pointed out and
I think that these efforts are now
bearing fruit and you can see that I
think
provides most of the questions thank you
but
um thank you very much Madame Lorenzo
for this very good overview of the
situation we will continue to follow
closely and in the view of forthcoming
app admission to Chile and Brazil the in
June this year
I hope that the insights will be much
clearer for the members of this house
thank you so much
so just for the members the meeting will
continue at 11 o'clock with the votes
thank you no